a movie that 95% of the world can relate
to to the other 5% yeah this movies also
kind of about you Horrible Bosses I
don't care who you are if you're in the
working world you've had a horrible boss
one that you've probably wished dead and
if you haven't well don't worry just
means you haven't been working long
enough now Horrible Bosses is about
three normal guys and three different
jobs we're all friends who just hate
their bosses played by Jason Bateman
Charley day and that guy who reminds me
of Andy Bernard from The Office never
know his name but he's funny and their
bosses are actually horrible people two
out of the three are Kevin Spacey's
Jason Bateman's Baz and if you've seen
the trailer to the movie dude he's
horrible this is one of the biggest
piece-of-shit human beings I think I've
ever seen in a movie and Kevin Spacey
was just awesome in this role I mean the
guy's a good actor anyway but he
actually played a better Lex Luthor in
this movie they did in Superman that was
interesting and then on to not Andy
Bernard from the office his boss his
boss is played by Colin Farrell when I
saw the trailer I didn't even know that
was Colin Farrell he just looked like a
sleazy douchebag with a comb-over and
then it was like Colin Farrell I was
like holy [ __ ] that's like Tom Cruise
from Tropic Thunder yeah he's a slimy
little piece of [ __ ] too then on to
Charlie days boss Jennifer Aniston who
he hates because she's sexually
harassing him and by Charlie Day I mean
that also means a guy who looks like
Charlie days being sexually harassed by
Jennifer Aniston yeah I got no sympathy
for that she is way hot in this movie
but that's probably because I'm a perv
who digs freaks so they'll get drunk and
they start cloud talking they're like
yeah it would be great if our bosses
could just die you know we should kill
our bosses and so they're like yeah
actually that's a good idea let's do
that so they'll plot to kill each
other's bosses and the movie was
actually really funny I mean the movies
about these three normal average
everyday dude type clowns so we're gonna
do something that you know normal people
really don't do or do we and so they're
like we're not gonna do this so we need
to get a hitman so they go and find
Jamie Foxx who really doesn't play a big
part in the movie he cameos like twice
so the two parts he was in were pretty
funny if you're able to sit back and
enjoy and relate to the fact these three
guys are trying to do what you've wanted
to do for years yeah I'm talking to you
you're gonna have a good time with
Horrible Bosses I promise the movie was
a lot of like breaking into the houses
and trying to plan how to kill the
bosses I would have rather have seen
like more failed attempts on the boss's
lives or something but in the end I like
the movie I like the humor is really
well-written like the dialogues just
really funny I mean usually in a movie
like this once the funny one and the
other two are just like you know there
we found all three of the guys funny in
their own way I like the characters I
like the bosses for what they were I
mean I don't like the bosses but I like
how douchey they were except for
Jennifer Aniston seriously dude I'm
telling you in this movie my whole body
was blue it was crazy of the things that
come to my mind when thinking about
having her as a boss killing her not one
of them I'm a little biased on that one
I'm just saying in the end I'll say it's
a good time no alcohol required I
thought it was a hundred times better
than bad teacher movie about killing a
douchebag boss it's pretty much like the
movie I've waited to see all my adult
working life I've had a douchey boss
I'll say right now I work for this one
dude he talks thank-thanks and he was a
really passive-aggressive piece-of-shit
douchebag and week after week he wasn't
paying people for a certain like
necessary part of the job that they had
to do so I was like hey I called the
corporate office and they said yeah you
have to pay the people for that so you
go ahead and start doing that and he was
just like I'm thank you for making me
look back you know what how about I just
take away those privileges right there
and then when everyone finds out though
I'll blame you he really talks like that
I gotta think somehow he's gonna end up
watching this if so hey how you doing
yeah you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] so for
you guys what's the douchiest boss
you've ever had no you had to have had a
douchey boss comment below let me know
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you